she just pulled the Kanye West I got
Kanye she got Kanye
an American Idol contestant gets revenge
after being Kanye during Sunday's
episode 20 year old Amara Valerio from
Yonkers New York opened up to judges
Katy Perry Luke Bryan and Lionel Richie
about singing the National Anthem at her
high school when I started to sing this
girl who came up and pulled the mic and
was like this is my senior graduating
class and I think I deserve to sing the
national anthem no what
this is good and crazy Amara even had
the video footage to prove it
[Music]
hi this is my um senior graduating class
and I would like to see she just pulled
the Kanye West
yep she got Kanye definition and
unwelcomed Interruption I'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
of course the origin of that verb stems
from this moment at the 2009 MTV VMAs
when yay interrupted Taylor Swift's
acceptance speech
I'm really happy for you I'm let you
finish but Beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time I was really excited
because Kanye West was on the stage and
then I um then I wasn't so excited
anymore after that I got Kanye she got
Kanye
and then the next year was covid so I
never got to sing in my high school
graduation either I want to feel
feel that and I need that thing
Navy sealed yeah the judges weren't
messing around in fact last year Katie
told E.T that they feel protective of
the contestants on the show we support
them we nurture them we give them
constructive criticism and they're
really entering into a a university as
Lionel likes to put a a crash course a
fast-paced crash course of the music
industry you want to sing a little that
chorus and dedicate it to someone that
shall not be named so they can't be
looked up let's go
I'll bust the windows out your car
what's her name what's her name
Amara nailed her performance of bust
your windows by Jasmine Sullivan and
reluctantly revealed her Bully's name is
Sarah an eye for an eye makes the whole
world blind but Sarah
hahaha you're finished messing with our
girl wow girl that's our girl Amara and
Amara she got the sweetest Revenge
of nowhere
[Music]